thank you
good morning
this is Ann Barker I'm actually in Tempe
Arizona today so good morning or good
afternoon Wherever You Are
my uh my former roles actually were uh
as deputy director of the National
Cancer Institute
and they are I was able to do a number
of things that I'm going to be reviewing
today I am currently at Arizona State
University where I am the co-director of
complex adaptive systems here and I'm
also director director of transformative
Healthcare networks and um I'm going to
be talking to you today about
molecular based medicine what we call
personalized medicine or Precision
medicine it's got a lot of names but
essentially it's molecularly based
medicine
and I'm going to ask the question is is
this our best hope to finally defeat
cancer and I'll give you the take-home
message uh I'm pretty optimistic but
there are some issues and we're going to
go through those in some detail today I
encourage you to ask questions as we go
through uh The Talk today and we'll try
to answer all of your questions and
clarify as we go through if that would
be helpful so so welcome to everybody
and those folks that were just on with
Chuck Peru I hope you learned an
enormous amount about what the great
things that Chuck has done for the
cancer genome Atlas in terms of breast
cancer so
um today we're gonna we're gonna walk
through several areas that I think are
going to be very important in
determining whether or not this is our
best hope for finally defeating cancer I
want us to talk about some of the
realities that we're facing in this
field and uh it's a it's a very old
field actually uh goes back uh Way
Beyond 1971 when we actually when
Richard Nixon Nixon actually approved
the National Cancer Institute the work
started well before then and continues
obviously to this day with a very very
big Enterprise behind it including the
National Cancer Institute and certainly
the private sector and and increasingly
foundations and others working in the
research Arena
the state of the science is uh is
evolving quite rapidly and driven in
large measure by Advanced Technologies
most especially whole genome sequencing
and next-gen sequencing which we'll talk
a bit more about
and we want to talk about sort of how
did we how do we evolve this strategy in
molecularly based medicine and why do we
think it's really important and why do
we think that we should continue down
this road and if we continue down this
road where should we be looking and what
should we be looking for
so and then finally let's look at the
near term and the and the future in
terms of things that we have to do to
really realize this potential so
um so to get started uh let's face some
realities here
um
cancer is an extraordinarily daunting
disease not just the nature of this
disease the heterogeneity of the disease
on the complexity Etc but just the sheer
numbers if you look at cancer in the
United States
we have about
1.6 million new cases that we're going
to diagnose this year and I should tell
you that substantially increasing
um men have about a one and two lifetime
chance of getting cancer and women one
in three
580 000 plus people will die this year
from this disease it's uh it's an
enormous number and again that's
increasing about that's it's going to be
about 25 percent of our living
population today and uh that's that's an
enormous number when you start thinking
of the size of our country
um an interesting statistic that is a
grim reality for this country because of
the baby boomer generation is that 77 of
cancer is diagnosed in individuals over
the age of 55 and if you think about the
fact that about 10 000 people are
turning 65 each day in the U.S you can
start to imagine that cancer is going to
increase and its projected to increase
somewhere in the neighborhood of 30
percent in the next 15 to 20 years and
that's that's all very bad news but the
good news is that they're about 13.7
million survivors today many more
survivors and much of that is due to
some of the targeted treatment that
we'll be talking about the cost of
cancer uh is is well over 200 billion
dollars a year and that that's going to
increase enormously this is one of the
largest problems we have in health care
today and finally
mortality rates overall have not shifted
all that much starting to shift a little
bit in the last five or six years but
not so much since the 1950s due to the
increased numbers of people getting
cancer and as we'll talk about later
that's an area where we have to focus
the reality is just not a U.S reality
this is a world problem and when I was
at the NCI we spent a lot of time
talking to other countries about their
cancer problem and as you can see in
2008 there were about 7.6 million cancer
deaths projected by 2020 there will be
about 10.3 million and it's going up
significantly from there
uh and if you look at 16 million new
cases in that same year that's going to
be an enormous burden for the world not
just for the U.S or for Europe or for
China but if you think about China China
has 350 million smokers and as you know
at least in our country and around the
world about a third of cancer is caused
by smoking so this is a huge issue in
China and will be and become more of an
issue as time goes on
so one of the other realities we face is
is metastatic disease as you can see
these numbers are a little better than
when I made this slide uh about a little
over a year ago but if you have if you
have not a static disease at the time of
diagnosis your chances of recovering and
surviving your disease might become much
much less and Regional disease is still
much more curable than distant
metastases and for some of these tumors
like pancreatic cancer we really still
don't do very well in terms of really
saving cancer patients and these are
areas that are enormous focused for for
for institutes like the National Cancer
Institute and for many of the survivors
groups so um
that's all that's all about the daunting
statistics that we're going to consider
for the moment and that's heaven knows
that's enough but the reality of what
this is actually led to over the many
years that we've been trying to actually
cure this disease and treat this disease
more effectively is that we have a
pipeline or a drug development process
that hasn't done very well so if you
look at this slide you'll see that from
the time we start in the discovery you
say of small molecules to improving uh
approving actually a drug FDA approving
a drug it costs us about a billion
dollars and it takes about 15 to 20
years now that is in large measure due
to the complexity of this disease and
the lack of effective biomarkers there
are other reasons but the heterogeneity
of the disease and complexity for cancer
is has been a daunting problem and
remains a daunting problem and even as
we move toward molecular medicine
if you um if you think if you think that
it would be appropriate
and you have questions as we go through
this talk please ask them as we go along
so
um
we don't have all of our questions at
the end so let's talk a little bit now
about the state of cancer research and
um if you look at where we all started
down this road it started when all the
way back in 1990 when there was there
was the national attempt to sequence the
human genome which turned into a major
major project a very successful project
one of the most uh one of probably one
of the most transformative projects of
our time
if you look at what that project
actually uh really enabled it was the
ability for us to identify these changes
in genes and changes in chromosomes
actually at every level of the genome
whether it was copy number changes big
changes in the genome or in the
chromosomes RNA expression micro rnas
which are much more recent but
extraordinarily important point
mutations uh the proteome the epigenome
ETC so if you go if you go to if you go
to the literature today you will find
all of these areas being explored and if
you think about how far we've come in
terms of the knowing the numbers of
genes knowing the number of base pairs
in DNA and knowing that we are still
pretty dismal in terms of knowing
function only about 50 percent of what
we know about the genome in terms of
mutations or changes in the genome have
actually enabled us to understand
function so this is our challenge
understanding changes in the genome is
step one understanding the functional
changes that occur as a consequence is
is step two through whatever and we're
we've got a lot of work to do there and
that in fact is probably our biggest
issue in terms of realizing the promise
of molecular-based Medicine
the other thing I want to point out at
this stage and it is an area of research
for the cancer Community has been for
many many years and that is that cancer
occurs in context
so the micro environment the
architectural issues related to how DNA
gets expressed or how it gets
interpreted by a cell within a cell is
incredibly important the last thing I'll
point out uh is that you know this is a
this is a trip that we haven't been on
all that long the first timecogene was
actually discovered in only in 1986 so
this progress has been pretty rapid and
if you think about where we are now
versus where we can go I think we can
expect exponential progress at this
stage
so I want to I want to pause here for a
second and think about uh what it is
that really started us on this road and
and really catalyzed more thinking about
uh what how can we actually understand
the genome and is understanding The
genome our best ticket to really uh
eliminating suffering and death due to
cancer hopefully curing a lot more
cancer
so this is a drug that was developed in
and approved in 2002 uh gleevac uh
imatinum for chronic myelogenous
leukemia and this is a very interesting
story and one that is worth knowing a
lot about because it has matured and
today we know a great deal more about
this drug and a great deal more about
this particular change in the genome
which has allowed us to understand a lot
more about other diseases so if you look
at this particular change in the genome
it's a fusion genome it's a it's an
exchange actually between two
chromosomes chromosome 9 and chromosome
22 to create a new construct actually
and that new construct leads to a new
protein that new protein as Brian
Drucker and his colleagues found out
when they started working on this
particular alteration the genome drives
a great deal of what happens in chronic
myelinus leukemia and so that drug was
approved in 2002 and lo and behold many
of those patients many of whom actually
were near death were were virtually
cured now that was the good news the bad
news is
um cancer is extraordinarily intelligent
I put that in quotation marks disease so
there are all kinds of backup mechanisms
that cancers evolved and so we do have
resistance uh in a in a percentage of
these patients and we now have second
and third generation drugs to treat
these patients but this was a really
instructive point and and I think one
that influenced a lot of what came after
in terms of expecting that we would find
a lot more of these kinds of changes in
the genome that hasn't proven to be the
case but we have found one more recently
the B rap Gene which actually uh is is
turning out to be a very important uh
change in the genome as well and we'll
come back to that one in a minute but
this has been uh was instructive in for
a couple of other reasons this
particular drug was very effective in
CML but as it turns out it's also
effective against another change in the
genome called secant so this particular
drug this is an fdg pet response uh to
gist or gastrointestinal tumors this
drug actually is very effective against
these tumors and actually a magnum is
effective against several kinds of
tumors now and that's a story that's
going to be very interesting if you
start thinking about this here's one
change in the genome that imatinum is
working against and another one that is
also working again
it's a it's a very interesting sort of
dynamic that's that we're beginning to
understand that these genomes the
changes some of these changes are going
to be common across several cancers some
are going to be very unique so you've
got to look at you got to look at the
drug very carefully and and and test it
in clinical trials against several
diseases so um
we in 2003 uh Francis Collins and I uh
had a conversation we had many
conversations with our board at the
National Cancer Institute is it time
given given what had gone on in
Discovery what we knew about the human
genome from the Human Genome Project is
it time to sit down and and talk about
doing a big science project uh for the
cancer genome and the answer was yes we
decided to do that in 2003 so we set up
the cancer genome Atlas
um some people like it some people don't
like it it's a big science I personally
believe that we are the stage in science
where we need to balance big science and
r01 or individual investigator initiated
science the goal here was to identify
all the genomic changes in up to what
became 20 different Cancers and I think
you heard from Chuck Peru on on the last
talk about some of the things that tcgi
has accomplished in in breast cancer
since the a very big project everything
in this project was highly controlled
from the samples and the quality of the
samples to pretty much everything about
the data how the data was actually
deposited how the data elements were
selected how we managed the data in
terms of the data repository and we also
had analytical teams to work on the data
and we had technology development that
both nhgri and NCI uh funded during that
period so um
a very big science a very big project
and many Publications now in nature
cataloging various mutations that we
have found in tcga some very interesting
some confirming what we already knew
which is an extremely important step
when you think about the fact that
thousands of people have worked on these
genomes and we need we need confirmatory
kinds of projects like this to ensure
ourselves that this is that these data
are real
so we use multiple Technologies here we
started with with Sanger sequencing we
worked our way through and actually
adopted next-gen sequencing and uh we we
looked at on various states of the
genome RNA obviously changes in the DNA
the epigenome we did not
consider we did not work on the proteome
in this project specifically some of our
colleagues did in some of the centers
and there were a number of centers
obviously working together on this
project and literally hundreds of
investigators so
um if you think about the kinds of
things that come out of projects like
this and there are other projects like
tcga now out there
this was this was actually
um the first two were we reported on
which was dbm or glioblastoma multiforme
which is an extraordinarily lethal tumor
as you know at the time we started this
investigation with tcga there there
wasn't much in the literature that
actually would inform us about this
tumor in terms of how to treat it how to
diagnose it
so what we were able to do is as we as
we worked as we worked our way through
this
um
we were able to
map these map these changes in the
genome pretty systematically and this is
the expression RNA expression and we
were able to actually subclassify these
tumors and this has been done since with
ovarian cancer and and other cancers but
essentially it also allowed us to take
the pathways and as you can see here the
rtk RAS pi3 kinase pathway the p53
pathway the RB pathway these were
Pathways that we knew a lot about but we
were able to map the genomes and the
changes in the genome to these Pathways
which substantially improved and
increased our confidence that for
example the tyrosine kinase is we know
they're important in cancer we know
they're important targets but this was a
great way to start to look at this and
found here and this is this is probably
one of the best databases out there for
GBM many many investigators now working
on this tumor and lots of new drugs
coming along and being tested for gvm
unfortunately not moving nearly as
quickly as we would like but I think in
the next four to five years you will see
some significant changes in the way GBM
was diagnosed and treated
um
so if you look at what tcga did and
several other of the large genome
projects including an international
project that actually uh used a lot of
the learning curves that we had
developed in tcga the international
cancer Genome Project
um being run by by Tom Hudson out of
Canada but if you look at what this has
created we've kind of created a
sequencing tsunami now I mean we have we
have a lot of sequencing going on and
we're sequencing not just cancer but
certainly across many and and almost all
diseases now but if you start to if you
start to look at if you start to look at
this it's really based not just on the
reduce reduced cost of sequencing
genomes but also on the amount of
information that's coming from the
genomes and nher is is
recommending uh that you know that we
are to start to really begin to
systematically look at this data and and
and are creating new approaches to that
for analysis and and other approaches
but it's projected that by the end of
2014 there will be a million uh genomes
and the total total Global output is
going to be about 28 petabytes of data
by 2014 that's an enormous amount amount
of sequence an enormous amount of
information we don't know how to manage
that and it's a huge challenge for us in
cancer probably the biggest challenge we
have right now and if you look at who's
producing all this data it's pretty much
coming from everywhere from the
international projects from tcga from
pretty much everywhere and the NCI
designated cancer centers are engaged
the Pharma bio company certainly engaged
and so we do from the sequencing tsunami
we now have a big data tsunami and you
hear a lot about Big Data these days
very important and particularly
important in terms of cancer
so increasingly it is about Big Data
increasingly many of you out there that
are working in the genome space know how
challenging this is in terms of analysis
uh it's it's a it's a huge problem and
one that as I say NCI is working on NIH
is working on certainly lots of private
initiatives in this area especially also
in Europe
uh and there there's a book out that you
haven't picked it up yet you might want
to look at it
um this is now becoming known as sort of
the fourth Paradigm science but
essentially uh this is uh what
biomedicine is going to become or is
quickly becoming uh information and big
data is in fact going to be the future
of biomedicine so uh those of you out
there that trained in uh differential
equations and haven't forgotten your
um your computational skills uh you're
going to be well served in the future
because this is uh it's going to become
increasingly important we don't have
enough people trained in this space I
wish we had a great deal more I know
many of our colleges and universities
are trying to catch up in this area now
so if you look at the data explosion in
in cancer and in biomedicine overall it
takes three different forms in terms of
variety there's just different forms of
the things that we're sequencing and and
finding out about the genome the sheer
rate or the velocity is is almost
exponential now and the amount of volume
as I said is is absolutely unprecedented
so if you look at all the data types and
you put all of this together in terms of
the multi multi-dimensionality of this
data 28 petabytes that we were talking
about before starts to look realistic
and pretty daunting in terms of the
amount of analysis we have to do and as
I said we now only know about 50 percent
of the functional changes that are
involved with the data that we know
something about so
um very very big problem
so the beauty of this uh era that we're
living in right now and I think we'll
all look back on this era as one where
we're beginning to open a new window
into understanding the complexity of
this disease
this big data really if we manage it
correctly and we put the right teams
together I think we can start to
deconvolute the complexity of this
disease in ways that we wouldn't have
guessed even five years ago and I'm
going to spend a minute on that at the
end of The Talk
so the way we're starting to think about
cancer and the way I like to think about
cancer and the way I'd like you to start
thinking about cancer is as follows this
is a complex information driven system
under the influence of evolution and it
evolves in Space over time now that's a
lot to think about but I would challenge
you to start thinking about the
four-dimensional genome not just the
two-dimensional genome because whatever
the cause on on the side of your screen
it's my left I don't know if it's your
left it can be inherited which is not a
not a large percentage of cancer but it
can be caused by so many different
things including smoking as we mentioned
before and certainly diet
wherever you start in terms of the
changes in the genome
everything after that is actually under
the influence of evolution all the way
up to the malignant state but this is a
system composed of many subsystems so we
need to start thinking about this to
understand function we're going to have
to understand a lot more about the
four-dimensional genome
so if you look at the way we see outside
patients and UC patients as you sequence
them even though if you look at this
going back to the sub the subtyping of
GBM every every line on there actually
is an individual patient
no two patients are going to be exactly
the same
but there are common features in these
Pathways that unite them almost like
snowflakes I put snowflakes on one side
of the screen here because as you know
in physics there are there are some
really interesting structural features
and physics of snowflakes that make them
look very much the same on a growth
basis but very very different when you
get down to the to the Nano space and so
the same thing may very well we may need
to start the thinking of patients and of
the science of what we're dealing with
in the same way so the the pathways that
we're talking about are quite common the
extent to which patients changes occurs
in those Pathways is quite different
so um
finally I want to I want to turn to the
question that we ask when we started
this conversation and that is is
molecular based medicine our best chance
to defeat cancer and
I'm going to give you a maybe right
because I wanna bring up a few issues
and
to realize the potential of whatever we
have here and I think we do have an
external extraordinarily good
opportunity to do a lot more about this
disease
so there are several barriers
um I'm going to just I'm going to talk
about two of those barriers this morning
but
one that's close to my heart is this
issue of high quality data best
practices and standards for the areas
that are driving biomarker development
and and biomarkers are actually signals
of either normalcy in a in a cellular or
or
a process that actually signals that
something is is okay or something is not
okay in the case of disease
um the and but there are other there are
other barriers here like as I said
before translating data into knowledge
is probably one of our biggest barriers
uh clinical trials and realigning and
redesigning clinical trials to
accommodate a personalized medicine
approach economic realities of this
who's going to pay for it engaging
patients this has to be patient-centric
and then some of the ethical issues that
surround this a whole issue of molecular
medicine are all things that have to be
dealt with but I want to talk a little
bit about this issue of standards and
and and quality in this space and then
also how do we talk and think about this
four-dimensional genome we can do a lot
more than we're currently doing
so if I
if I take you back to the country
General Atlas for a second we learned a
lot in that particular project about the
value of standards and the value of
actually having high quality tissues of
actually sourcing those tissues uh in
ways that where their their collected
under standard operating procedures uh
it turns out to be pretty important and
even though technology is moving very
quickly now the significance of
reproducibility of data and
reproducibility of findings is
incredibly important especially again
around biochemical biomarkers and I
would argue that quality tissues and
access to Quality tissues is going to be
critical and is going to be more and
more difficult in the future because
we're getting better and better actually
at preserving uh preserving tissues and
also in preserving life so we're by the
time we get around to taking out many of
these tumors we've actually shrunk them
and so we're we're actually where we
like but we're also we're also
decreasing the amount of tissue that
we're going to have available so but one
thing we learned here and it was a
learning curve that cost us uh time and
it also cost us resources was that at
that time and I'm not sure how much has
changed only about a third of our
tissues in the country were good enough
to use in the early going of the cancer
genome Atlas and um so quality is
important and I think it's now become
very important to most of you out there
and
um the second area that is I think
reflects some of these problems not just
in tissues but also lack of standards
and um
in the technology space is that we are
not very good at developing biomarkers
and well we're not very good at all in
developing biomarkers we've discovered
about 150 000 in the literature about
a thousand of those have actually made
it through the FDA only about 1.3 per
year since the early 90s and the reasons
are complex but a lot of them have to do
with reproducibility of data and the
quality of the of the analytes that
we're working on so this has to be fixed
otherwise we can like all the
discoveries we want but we have to have
decent biomarkers to to pair up with the
kind of drugs that we want to get
approved
so if you look at what we're going to do
about the biomarker problem and the
standards problem overall for biomarkers
we don't currently have a prospective
way to think our through think our way
through a pipeline to actually develop
an end-to-end approach to biomarker
development it just doesn't exist it's
been done piecemeal over many years and
channel Woodcock who's the director of
the center for drugs at the FDA has said
it's not fda's job to develop the
standards for biomarkers it's it's the
job of the affected communities so I'll
just mention one of the things that we
have done here at Arizona State
University in actually in collaboration
with many partners the critical path
Institute the international genome
Consortium Mayo Clinic
t-gen and many national groups as well
now is to take this problem on so we've
developed something called the national
biomarker development Alliance we'll be
launching that in January of 2004 14 and
our mission actually as this pipeline
into indicates is to create a standard
set of standards and best practices so
that we can actually come up with a
prospective predictable end-to-end
pipeline for the express purpose of
bringing rigor and predictability to
biomarker development we think that will
really really help our communities to
get their drugs approved to get their
biomarkers approved and accelerate the
pace by which we can get these targeted
drugs into patients so it's a big tent
if any of you interested in joining me
in this and joining our colleagues in
this just email me and we'd love to have
you join us so um coming back to this
issue of complexity I want to spend my
final few minutes here on talking about
how this cancer Community can Embrace
complexity and think about think more
deeply about the four-dimensional genome
this is where progress will be made in
my opinion so coming back to cancer is a
complex system and all the excuse me all
the all the discussion that we've had
about this sorry
still get you can still make mistakes
when you have everything under your
control there but coming back to this
idea that cancer is a complex system
it's not just a complex system in the
sense that you're looking at it in a
linear fashion you have to look at it in
terms of the subsystems and the
interaction that goes on in in
three-dimensional space and over time
and and time is a big component in
cancer when you think about it because
it takes and with many of these cancers
it takes decades to develop these
diseases so we need to understand a lot
more about how these changes in the
genome get expressed in terms of this
four-dimensional idea and if we can do
that then we'll start to take what we
now look at as Pathways and this is a
Hanahan Weinberg slide that lots of
people show but essentially
cancer is a is an emergent system it's a
it's actually the consequence of the
interaction of so many of these Pathways
over time and in space so just looking
at these Pathways as we diagram them
today it's convenient but it's not that
simple and so we have to start thinking
about these Pathways as they interact
and how this disease emerges and so very
very important for all of us to start
changing our mindset about the linearity
of Pathways that's not the way it works
in nature and it's not the way it
certainly it works in in the human body
so if you start to think about this let
me just click quickly through this and
click back
sorry
so if you start to think about how
information Drive systems within systems
then if you look at cancer as a system
there are all kinds of length scales
starting with cancer it starts down with
their genome or even at below the genome
actually at the at the molecular level
or even at the atomic level we don't do
much in cancer at that level yet but I
predict someday we will but essentially
you've got to start thinking across
scales all the way from DNA up to the
organism and if you look at the
variables then you you you're going to
move from the changes in DNA all the way
up to the organism and these systems
obey the laws of physics it doesn't
necessarily explain their behavior
because it's an emergent system so the
subsystems can can actually behave in
some way but the emergent system May
behave differently and we see that in
cancer and heterogeneity actually
produces a lot of things that we can't
control so these behaviors that we see
in cancer whether is the immersion of
this emergence of metastasis or
resistance or the ability to actually
physically these cells to move from one
place to the other you can't you can't
really explain this by understanding the
components so each of these components
is part of a complex system and I would
argue that's the future how do we
understand complex systems cancer is
information it's decoded in context and
so shape matters context matters
infrastructure matters this is all
information and the information is being
translated between the context of
architecture and DNA and people who
worry about the microenvironment are
starting to really make contributions I
think in this field
so I think the future belongs to teams
of people who who are going to work
together from theorists in terms of
evolutionary theory information Theory
I.T and computational and
bioinformaticians and physics and
Engineering helping us to understand
some of the physics of these systems and
then biologists who actually are
developmental biologists cancer
biologists Etc and I think this
increasing complexity across all of the
areas that we think about from the DNA
up to the organism is going to be the
future of the way we think and work with
this disease and other complex chronic
diseases but cancer is especially going
to be relevant to this kind of approach
so I have guarded optimism that
molecular-based medicine is our best
hope to finally defeat cancer I think
we're starting to show some real hope in
that regard and um
here's the best hope of all uh if this
is just a list of some drugs that have
been approved for cancer starting with
perceptin which was actually a first to
the targeted drugs approved all the way
back I think in 2000 if I remember
correctly this is uh this is actually
her2 which is an amplified Gene in
breast cancer and that was actually
worked on and and pushed forward by
Denny Simon at UCLA and is used very
almost universally in breast cancer
today
Russian in terms of urban talks is now
is we have several approved drugs beyond
the list that's on here
k-ras is a very interesting example of
understanding The genome in more detail
than we would have thought even
important a few years ago the wild type
of this particular Gene these cancers
respond if in fact they are mutated KRS
genes they generally do not respond it's
not it's not an absolute guarantee that
if you're a wild type that you'll
respond but a very major percentage of
those patients do but what's really
important is knowing who's not going to
respond so this is a another example of
an approved drugs a series of drugs now
to treat this disease for patients
especially with wild type KRS more
recently the brat Gene discovered many
years ago now has been shown to be very
important in melanoma and we have we
have several drugs now approved for
metastatic melanoma just in last five
years along with and I should say all of
these drugs have approved biomarker
tests now there are issues with the
tests and one of the things that going
back to the plants of the national
biomarker development rights we hope to
work out these issues in terms of
building better biomarker tests even her
too to this day starts continues to be
an issue so we'll come back to we'll
come back to that at the end potentially
with questions so
I'm getting random my time and I want to
make sure that I have some time to
discuss with you some of these issues so
in the near future here's what I think
some things uh here's some things that I
think will need to happen to realize
this whole future of personalized
molecular-based medicine number one we
have to engage patients
um in all
acts of this process
this is about personalized patient
focused medicine and so we need to do
clinical trials and inform clinical
trials of patients and so engaging
patients is going to be critical and I
think more and more scientists
understand that and are beginning to
work with survivors groups in ways that
we haven't done before and that's going
to be very productive
um we have to know that our molecular
signatures or our biomarkers are
extremely robust and reproducible now as
you know the literature that's been
literature recently showing that we have
some issues in that regard some actually
a fair percentage of some of the work
done in biomarker science especially
it's not been reproducible and we need
to know that there's no bias in that
work that the nature of high quality Etc
because that's the work that's going to
get translated by the pharmaceutical
companies large amount of dollars are
going to be invested and we need to be
very careful that we are in the
discovery Community producing robust
data that's translatable and also
reproducible
we need we really need to start engaging
more with computational experts and and
modelers and we have this is occurring
now
um it's I think it's still pretty modest
and um you know my my advice is is to
take a mathematician to launch and
interest them in your science and
interest them in your data because if
we're going to functionalize this data
we have to engage people who really
understand how to look at data and there
are people that outside our field who
know a lot more about this than we do
for example people who forecast the
weather they have great models to look
at huge big data sets earthquake
modelers I mean so it may sound a little
strange the the the
economists there are other people who
know how to look at big data sets we
need to learn from them we need to
engage with them very difficult but
doable and a lot of those people would
love to work with us especially the
Googles and and Microsoft folks of the
world those are people who we need to
engage with
um
we knew we need new and much better
clinical trial models than we currently
have especially for our biomarker driven
clinical trials and we need we need
trials like the I spy 2 trial one that I
was able to work on and and help to
enable it when I was at National Cancer
Institute still involved with that trial
led by Laura Esserman and Don Berry now
moving to I spy three but this is an
Adaptive trial that allows us to look at
lots of biomarkers and lots of drugs if
you don't know about I spy 2 you can go
go to the literature there are several
several Publications out there now on
Ice by one and I spy 2 and also the
battle trial MD Anderson and other
trials there's a new lung cancer trial
coming along as well
so um another thing we need is these
best practices standards guidelines for
biomarkers which don't exist again
that's something that I'm taking on and
I'm hoping that some of you will want to
join me in that we need the evolutionary
biologists involunteer we don't we don't
have great strengths in terms of
evolution in cancer we know that it's
very important but we we haven't thought
about how you actually model to
prospectively understand for example
resistance and I think Evolution's
incredibly important in terms of
understanding resistance to the to the
to the drugs that we're administering
and then last but not least for this
field to be important enough for payers
to actually pay for it which is going to
be critical uh whether you you know
whether you're in the whether you're in
the payer Community or in the
development Community or in the
discovery Community there has to be a
value proposition here so we we the
scientific Community is going to have to
demonstrate them value of molecular
based medicine so that we can we can
actually entice the payers and encourage
the payers to pay for this and that's
not a small issue because the value
proposition needs to be demonstrated in
very sound ways and in clinical trials
finally
in the more distant future I think a lot
of things are going to change they're
going to really accelerate progress in
this space a molecular-based medicine
first of all we need to understand
more about the information that's
driving complexity whether it's uh use
of models or actually sort of the
definition of State space as physicists
see it or mathematically modeling the
information that we need but we need to
understand what it is that is most
important in terms of deconvoluting the
complexity of this disease especially
the Pathways in the interacting Pathways
so we can identify these sensitive nodes
which are going to be our bio signatures
in the future I think
so coming back to this idea of evolution
in context we may we need to actually
engage with Scientists who understand
and measure bits of information flow in
systems and how cells make decisions and
cells do make decisions they actually
decide to go down One path or another
based on information and we're getting
to a stage now where we can start to ask
those kinds of very difficult questions
so again I think the engagement of some
of the physicists mathematicians are
going to be very important and I know I
sound like a broken record on this but
very important that we take biology to
this convergent step so we can engage
these broader teams finally I think that
you know the Dynamics and information
content that we need to figure out in
terms of cellular communication it we're
just on the just on the edge of that and
so things like chemical gradients what
are what are signals in cancer and
chemical gradients is only one way to
sell signal but there are lots and lots
of other ways and those signaling nodes
are really what we need to go after in
terms of understanding how information
is transferred
finally
these Pathways for cancer are extremely
robust
Evolution has actually selected for them
so we need to describe that robustness
so we can understand how we can overcome
it and there this these robust pathways
are selected for and selected for and
selected for every time we give a drug
you need to also begin to define the
information that defines metastatic
disease so we won't we won't care about
a study disease until we understand
where does the information reside how is
the information transferred and how can
we stop it
and I think that's going to be key
um and also you know what is the physics
of these processes around information
finally
cancerous tissue and organ specific and
we need
really to put more of our effort on
understanding the structural information
in the infrastructure that is that is
the tissues and the cells that actually
translate what comes from the genome
very very important big community in our
cancer world and I think they're going
to make an enormous amount of progress
in the next few years maybe we need a
cancer Genome Project for the micro
environment I wouldn't be surprised
so I'm going to stop there
um
we have about 15 minutes left for
questions you can send your questions in
and we'll try to answer them and I'm
going to go some of you have already put
some questions up and I want to I want
to take some of those on now and uh then
we'll we'll come back and close
so um
here's a comment
um
that uh
is long but let me see if I can get it
um
so it's a question about secondhand
smoke it's is the number of cancers
attributed to smoking taking into
account secondhand smoke and the fact
that a third world smoker
sorry this is a very long question
um are smoking poor cigarettes lower
grade of cigarettes that's a very
interesting question I don't know the
answer to the quality of the cigarette
issue
but I do know that the number I gave you
does not and it does not include
um the issue of secondhand smoke I'm
only talking about primary smokers so
that's uh
that's another problem and a very big
problem obviously for the families of
these folks
um
so um
so
Titans is a second question on
biomarkers here talking about biomarkers
biomarkers except protein biomarkers for
complicated Pathways how reasonable is
it to study pathway gene expression
biomarkers will nbda accept these kinds
of research efforts the answer is yes
because I think I think expression
biomarkers are going to be very
important in terms of pathway biology
very difficult to actually interpret
very difficult to really understand and
correlate with changes in in disease but
I think there is I think we're entering
an era where we can with our
computational friends begin to develop
algorithms to capture the amount of
information that would be an expression
profile and there are people working on
that so I think this is a great area I
think it's one that we should not
underestimate but we do need to think
about some of the Practical
considerations of standardizing the
approaches and the best practices the
guidelines which many of you have worked
on over the years we don't need to run
did a lot of Wheels here so um so the
answer is yes very important as a matter
of fact I think made me more really
important most important maybe of some
of the biosignature issues
um
so are we collecting data from thyroid
cancer patients as well I haven't
mentioned it well I haven't mentioned a
lot of cancers but thyroid cancer
actually is uh Juno very serious problem
and yes uh there are several groups
collecting a lot of information on
thyroid cancers
um I don't believe I don't have the data
in front of me I don't believe that I
think we have tissues for the cancer
genome Atlas for the thyroid cancer I
don't think that cancer has been uh has
been run by the groups yet it was not in
the top 20 but there are several groups
that have that are sequencing thyroid
tissues and I think we will have good I
think we will have good data on thyroid
cancer it's a really interesting one and
and uh and essentially one that we
should be looking at more carefully it
is a it is a big problem in certain
countries more so than in the U.S
um so my favorite question what is the
four-dimensional genome well it's my
term for what we need to do and and it's
a bit of a play on words granted but if
you think about the way we're thinking
about the genome today essentially if
you lay out a sequence and I don't know
how many of you have looked at a genome
sequence but probably a lot of you have
by now uh you know we're we're laying
out a a lot of uh zeros and ones
essentially is what we're reading from
The genome visual information in two
Dimension two-dimensional space so what
I'm asking us to do is to think about
moving up in terms of thinking about
four-dimensional genomes in the sense
that let's think about let's think about
that genome in space three-dimensional
space and over time which would be the
fourth aspect so essentially it's a it's
a way to to bring together the
functionalization of the genome so I
think I you know I'm pointing this
phrase I don't know if I coined it and
somewhere or somebody else coined it but
I like it and hopefully we could pick up
on it and start thinking about how to
really delve into the four-dimensional
genome not just the two-dimensional
genome we're right now into the
four-dimensional genome producing lots
of big data but I would predict there's
going to be a lot of progress in that
especially in understanding that that
configuration between sort of spatial
issues and how uh how information is
transferred between the architecture of
the cell and uh and the digital changes
that occur in the genome and it's a
little bit I think it's hard for us to
wrap our mind around the fact that
The genome is digital information it is
zeros and ones it's it's it's very much
like a computer program and it's an
extraordinarily complex computer program
we know something about it but we need
to know a lot more and there's a lot
more in the genome actually actually
that we don't know probably than we do
know
um
so how can this is how can you get
involved and help to achieve your vision
of how cancer is defeated
well
there are so many ways it would take me
a lot more than the uh eight nine
minutes I have left here to tell you but
if you're if you're a scientist then I
hope that you're working in this space
of accelerating progress against cancer
whether it's in the basic science space
which I believe is incredibly important
I think a lot of our advances are going
to come from fundamental science in the
future
um whether it's in a translational space
and you think about how do you actually
develop very very high quality
biomarkers or how you develop very very
excellent drugs uh if you're in the if
you're in the farm industry or if you're
in the clinical trial space how do you
do better clinical trials if you're a
patient there are over 800 survivors
groups out there that you can get
engaged with if you're a professional
Society then we're you know we're we're
focusing on everything for example in
the American Association for cancer
research we're putting more focused on
policy we're focused on basic science
translational science clinical science
so there are so many ways and um and
finally make sure that you're talking to
Congress about supporting cancer
research because right now NIH and NCI
overall are taking a big hit and we need
our we need our fundamental science to
be supported we need our clinical
investigators to be supported so one of
the things that everybody can do is
write a letter and say we want to
support research
um so um there's a question here that is
one that is is a very big deal and one
that really worries me a lot uh
and that is this issue of most cancers
are diagnosed in late stages
specifically stomach cancer
when possible
um
stomach cancer is in fact treatable now
but not as treatable as we would like us
in in an advanced stage so
this question that's that's brought up
here is a really critical one is how do
we actually find this tumor earlier it's
a it's a similar problem that we have
with pancreatic cancer or GBM and others
and I think now with with uh with
gastric cancer especially and it is an
accessible cancer certainly you can you
can you can take biopsies you can do
work with stomach cancer that you can't
do with some of the other Cancers and so
I am hopeful for stomach cancer and it's
by the way it's emerging again in this
country I mean as you know it's caused
by H by Lori it's emerging against a
problem in this country and in younger
people we don't know why particularly
but it is and I am hopeful that we'll
use this very powerful genomics tool
that we have to begin to find those very
key genomic changes and we can start
looking for this tumor much earlier and
I think it is one that we can start to
look at in much much earlier than we are
now and I'm hopeful on that cancer as
I'm hopeful in everything but I think
gastric cancer is one of those where we
can do a great deal more
um the next question is do I see a link
between Cancer and autoimmune disease
um well I train as an immunologist so I
tend to see a link between immunity and
almost everything
autoimmune disease as you know is
extraordinary problem producing a whole
range of diseases I don't know the
answer to your question in terms of is
there a direct link but there are
certainly diseases where we have a
proliferation of cells and and some of
these Pathways I think may be
overlapping and the whole issue of the
immune system and cancer overall is
coming together and this last year has
kind of been the year for
immunotherapies I didn't mention as I
was going through that last couple
slides but FDA actually approved uh
since July of 2013 or 12 and up to today
has approved 11 new cancer drugs that's
amazing two and two immunotherapies so
immunotherapy and this whole issue of
using the immune system is becoming very
mainstream and very effective and the
understanding of the intersection of
autoimmunity in cancer I think is going
to be very important maybe not for all
cancers but potentially for some cancers
but at the moment we don't have that
many people working in the space so if
you are working in that space I I wish
you luck I think it's a very hard it's a
very hard area very hard problem but one
that has a wrong promise
um
so another question is a public LinkedIn
Community project a good idea as we have
already started one would you help us
if anybody as you know me I'm very much
the consummate volunteer I have a day
job but I'll help anybody I love the
LinkedIn idea I think it's very
important and I would be a way to get
you know get credentials out there and
we'd know people we could turn to for
help
so um
the next question is long are continual
models to consider unsteady State
diffusion and chemical reaction useful
to analyze and our Continuum models that
consider unsteady State diffusion and
chemical reaction useful to analyze and
interpret some of the large databases
that you mentioned and had there been
significant advances in quantifying the
kinetics of tumor growth let me answer
the first questions first
the answer is yes this whole issue of
the Continuum that you're talking about
in terms of cancer is is is not at
equilibrium this is an unsteady State
and it's one that lends itself to the
model that you're talking about so I
would say yes the models you're talking
about would be a very high value in the
cancer space especially in terms of some
of the Big Data you're talking about for
some of the cancers that have that have
great promise to be analyzed in this way
and then had there been significant
advances in quantifying the kinetics of
tumor growth
I think kinetics in the way that you're
talking about it not as much as we would
like we do understand some better I
think some tumors better than others but
in terms of having a real handle and
predictability on tumors in terms of
kinetics not yet but I think as we
involve more physicists I think we will
get there
um
I don't want to have time we got a lot
of questions
um which do you think will play a
greater part in demonstrating the value
proposition of personalized medicine I
think it'll be Diagnostics
and I'll stop there and I'll say that's
the biggest uh that's the biggest
barrier we have but I think it could be
also be the most productive because it
has the biggest payoff
uh assuming we identify the right
patients for the right drugs
um any comments on the on using animal
models to study the evolution of the
genome uh very powerful uh very useful
and I'm hoping we see more of it in the
space
can I comment on the role of
computational experts with protein
biomarker Discovery
very very important some of the major
advances in this space will be made by
computational experts working in the
proteomics space it is as close as we're
going to get to the state space and
understanding the space space State
space of cancer
um
so uh drug treatment pushes cancer to
progression and Drug resistance which is
a major change mutations what do we need
to obtain approval of the Diagnostics
and Drug together
you need reproducibility and you need
predictability and obviously you need
efficacy and I I think that that will
become more predictive as we get better
in the Diagnostics space
so um before I run out of time I want to
just look at the last list of questions
and see
here's an interesting one how do I see
emotional factors in terms of cancers
cancerous complexity I wish we knew the
answer to that we know that stress and
other issues are important but we don't
know why I wish more of our scientific
Community would look at that it's very
difficult to study
um
do for predisposition to cancer is
prophylaxis it's prophylaxis promising
promising extraordinarily difficult
so I'm going to stop there I didn't get
to every question I'm sorry about that
but you ask a lot of great questions I
am optimistic that that molecular-based
therapy is is going to take us much
further than we are in terms of
defeating cancer
is it the ultimate answer I think it
could be if in in fact we engage the
communities that I spoke about to bring
everyone to the conversation and
understand this four-dimensional genome
how the genomics is actually interpreted
in people
so thank you very much for joining me
today and have a great day